Last week, I mentioned to you that in the
36 hours or so after the tragic death of Supreme
Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg, one hundred
million dollars was donated to Joe Biden and
other Democrats, a real sign of enthusiasm,
to put it very, very lightly.
Well, we now have fundraising numbers from
Tuesday, and Joe Biden raised ten million
dollars during the three hour period surrounding
the first presidential debate with Donald
Trump in the first hour alone.
Joe Biden raised three point eight million
dollars.
This is a campaign fund raising record for
a single hour.
And then if you look at the nine p.m. to midnight
Eastern Bloc, ten million dollars raised.
Two hundred and fifteen thousand donations,
including 60000 new donors who had not previously
donated and one hundred thousand people signed
up to volunteer for the campaign.
Now, this is not a guarantee of anything.
We don't yet have Trump's fundraising numbers
to compare for during the debate.
But this is very good for Joe Biden.
And I feel like I don't even need to say this
now, but I will.
I hate how our elections are financed.
I despise the money system that we have.
But for the next 35 days, it's the system
that we have and the one that Joe Biden has
to use to win.
And seeing ten million dollars raised in three
hours is just stunning.
What seems them to be motivating lots of donations
is people realized when they were watching
the debate.
Trump doesn't want more people to vote.
Trump wants fewer people to vote.
There was no way to watch the debate and not
pay attention to the reality that Donald Trump
would prefer that you not vote, particularly
if you don't like him.
But on balance, Donald Trump has figured out
that all else being equal, he's better off
if he suppresses the vote.
And it was very transparent during that debate.
People didn't like it.
People saw it.
And they saw the completely undemocratic authority,
authoritarian nature of Donald Trump, who
also doesn't want to accept the election results
unless he wins and is preemptively saying
if the results are anything other than he
won, he will say that the results are rigged.
And this has motivated people to donate.
We will see where it gets us.
In just about a month.
But what what I like hearing about this is.
To put it lightly, there are a lot of ignorant
and uninformed people in this country who
fall for anything.
And 60 million of them fell for voting for
Trump in 2016.
Sixty million are likely going to fall for
it again.
What was for me inspiring to see was that
even though Donald Trump didn't come out and
say, I don't want people to vote, I want people
to stay home.
You know, he used sort of coded language.
People saw through it.
People watched it.
And they said, I can determine from what he
is saying, what he really means, and I don't
like it.
And I'm going to donate to Joe Biden.
So incredible numbers for Biden.
I'll have the Trump numbers for you when
they
are out.